so peter can share start sharing his
screen
yes right so it looks like recording has
started at least the
platform says so
so i thought of uh
um giving
kind of a background to
uh how we ended up doing what we do uh
give you a couple of examples uh from
the
stories that we built with vizu but most
importantly uh
get uh like a quick
deep dive into how our technology works
and and show you some examples uh of uh
how it can be used to to create uh
animated stories
of data
and
let me let me really quickly see if i
can share my screen
it looks like i have the opportunity to
do that
yeah so
the the whole thing you can see my
screen right
yes
okay great so the whole thing started
with something like this uh this is an
illustration from a lengthy research
that one of my co-founders andrew did
when he set out on a journey to identify
common
characteristics of data different data
visualizations
he's a designer by heart and a data
visualization expert and he got
frustrated by the fact that
data visualization always just comes as
an afterthought and it's it's very
abstract in the sense of you have to
have the analytical skills and you have
to know uh
like
not very intuitive software's to to
build charts and to make sense of those
and to build stories of those and his
original concept was that if we can
build a system that can generate all the
different types of charts and can
animate between them then we can build a
graphical user interface
for data that would enable sort of like
a dialogue and
and and enable people not to use
visualization just as an afterthought
but uh but but as a central element for
interacting with data looking for
insight uh and then then sharing these
insights and reusing them with others
and this this was like
this
is just one part of his his research
where he basically identified what
exactly is used in different child forms
and what type of the data is being shown
uh on on these different charts uh he
had uh like a huge spreadsheet where he
gathered these and and tried to
understand what type of
data can be shown in different charts
and then um because if uh this is
possible that wasn't uh for sure back in
the day uh that that such a system can
be built then uh
these
the system would be capable of animating
between these chart forms which is
obviously uh
like a good
thing if you think about
enabling people just to to follow along
a story to follow along these changes or
or when you ask questions of your data
and you or you try to look at it from
different angles if these views are
connected via the animation it's just a
lot easier for people to comprehend
what's going on but
it has its own rules how you animate
from one chart form to the other and
this is again just a small excerpt from
a huge tableau
that he did uh to understand what uh
would be necessary to to to make the
animation uh really um like
understandable basically and uh
yeah if we uh
fast forward i don't know like around
the year or so uh we we end up at this
point where
uh as you can see uh he and my other
co-founder simon
were able to to build this tool at first
when andrew approached others with his
idea a lot of people said that this
cannot be done but
actually the the energy that we built uh
proves that uh that
it can be done uh and now we have a
single engine that can generate all the
different types of charts that you can
uh see uh being illustrated here with
this within this short animation and
animate between them
uh how can this be useful what's the
benefit of all this so first of all uh
the obvious uh upside of of having
animated charts is to connect the views
and not having to necessarily describe
what's on each of the charts
since we are now very much focused on
the data science use case and and
helping data scientists tell stories
with data i ask
people about their experiences all the
time and data scientists
told us that whenever they make
presentations to non-data scientists
more most regularly business people
they spend around half of the time at
each slide which has a chart explaining
what can be seen on the chart and then
another half of the time explaining why
that matters
which is i think a total waste of time
if you could do the same thing with
animation where what i basically what
you can basically see here is
these views being connected uh used
using animation and no
other explanation is necessary from this
point i mean it's it's crystal clear
what's going on here but but animation
is
uh opens up also new possibilities uh
especially uh when you want to tell a
story when you want to uh invite someone
and share your way of thinking with them
it can you can
show changes over time you can
split
a complex
chart to its component and and you can
actually turn just one chart into a com
a full
full-on story just by you know showing
its element uh in in a in a proper order
and
what we did first we built some data
stories that we published on reddit i'm
going to show you a couple of examples i
know for those of you who were here in
the first time when i joined this
presentation for
this meetup group for a lightning talk
may have already seen this i'm sorry for
maybe being so showing you again uh some
of the same stuff but i just want to
make sure that everybody
being in the
meetup call can um you know understand
the full picture so this is for example
just a super simple use case it shows uh
how much
a cocoa bean farmer gets from a one
dollar chocolate bar and the animation
here is only used to
create build a narrative uh to also it
creates tension because you know the
farmer's share appear right towards the
end and
and but it you know it it uh it gives
you a lot of more it involves you a lot
more emotionally than if i was just to
show you how the one dollar is is being
split up
or this is also like a simple
uh video that shows
the
uh the size of the different continents
and then adds the uh the population of
these continents uh one by one and then
in the
third
column we will see uh the gdp being
generated uh by the people living there
uh and and as you could imagine there's
like huge differences in that regard uh
between the continents and we actually
created an interactive explorer uh in
which uh people you could just you know
switch uh from within these three
values and and check out uh
these this data for for each and every
country in the world
um
and it's and these were pretty popular
as you can see that over 60 000 upvotes
we had some other complex stories uh
like one about the presidential election
um
like two years back uh which which
explains uh how what
like the polls actually mean and that
it's a 51 separate races and we we have
one that shows uh like if you saw the uh
the chernobyl mini series and hbo how
much uh radiation the uh those guys who
were sent out on the roof to clear the
radioactive debris had to endure it
shows that in real time and it puts that
into context by adding some um you know
some other data points to to relate to
uh if if you're interested in such
stories just look for visio hq on reddit
and you will see uh some other uh stuff
that that even the hypocritical users of
reddit found interesting
we also made some interactive explorers
like this one this is about donald
trump's tweets
we can see the number of tweets he sent
from his account uh
the date is only up to
may 2020 but it's like most of his
tweeting career and now the caller shows
which platform he used when he was using
the web platform android iphone or some
other platforms and and with the use of
this interactive explorer that we built
the user could just click around and see
the data from different angles which is
like a more uh
advanced use case of of what our
technology is capable of like splitting
it up to see the trends side by side or
or just taking a look at the total
number of tweets and from
these
these platforms or even uh switch the
view to the time of day and and see uh
at which times of uh he sent these
tweets so
as you can see there are a couple of
peaks uh this is a 24-hour clock by the
way midnight is on top noon is at the
bottom
so there's like one at seven in the
morning and then one sometime in the
afternoon but if we filtered the results
based on the different periods like when
he was still a businessman you can see
that the the peak is definitely at uh at
three in the afternoon and there are the
famous tweet rants uh during the night
like i don't know sending 82 tweets
between 3 4 15 and 3 30 in the morning
whereas when he became president
uh the peak uh is at the
totally different place around seven in
the morning and the the the ninth
sessions uh seem to have ended
uh so this is uh already as i said a
more
advanced
use case of what our tool is capable of
and i just want to show you
my favorite insight here which is if we
compare the number of tweets to the
number of times these tweets were
retweeted which we can also do by click
of a button uh you can see that uh yeah
he he grew a little bit more interesting
for the users of the platform uh when he
became president and and right before
that and uh that's we really liked this
this graphic and call it the trump's
twitter trumpet because it there's even
a small bump here which we don't really
know what uh relates to
what it means but but it looks nice so
um yeah these were these were the early
days when we were still trying to figure
out uh how we can put the the early
versions of our technology to good use
and
then we we found
the data scientists and and their issues
with with sharing the results of their
analysis and we decided to focus on that
first uh the these are some this is
these are some important data points
from the state of data science research
that anaconda publishes every year the
next one is coming up in two weeks
we are in contact with with them already
and
and we hope to be participating with
sharing the the results of that with the
data science community but basically
what the data tells us is that uh data
scientists spend a lot of time with
reporting and presentation uh these the
inside are obviously important for
businesses but still uh getting the
message through uh is is troublesome and
it's it's not not as easy as it should
be and also we just we realized that the
current tools most of the data
scientists are using are not focused on
storytelling and presentation so we
thought if we
can build something for for them for you
guys uh that that helps you with this uh
that can be like a a good
start as as a startup we we obviously we
had a solution uh
or a couple of solutions with this
technology we had to find a problem and
this is a problem we're focusing on
right now so uh just to give you a quick
overview of how we ended up here uh the
core engine is written in c plus plus
that we use to build those stories and
interactives and and then and also
participate in some paid projects
was was used uh in-house then we
released uh
almost exactly a year ago on open source
javascript library because we decided to
to go this open source way and and get
the experts who can start using our
thing
it's already embedded into some live
products and then uh we uh we and we we
published our first uh
tool for for data scientists called ipai
visu that works within jupiter and other
computational notebooks this march
and uh just uh
less than two months ago on europa
island actually that was mentioned
before we
we publicly released a new extension of
ipivizu with which one can build uh
presentations uh within uh jupiter and
others and other notebooks and share
them as an interactive html i will show
you examples of these
so
we realized that that embeddability and
the open source approach is great
because it enables
us to
penetrate
different platforms with our technology
uh
even after three months after releasing
ipivizu it was already available in all
of these platforms that i'm pretty sure
you're you're i mean but most of you i'm
pretty sure you're already familiar with
most notably data science notebooks but
also it works nicely with price create
panel
mercury that enables you to build
interactive web apps from your notebook
and mode which is a which is a bi tool
that that allows you to run a notebook
inside so without further ado let me
show you how this
thing works but but if you have any
questions at this point i'm i'd be happy
to to answer uh before we we jump into
the how the actual technology works
anybody
oh hey
by the way i worked for mode so it's
really it was really good to see mode in
one of the slides
good
yeah very cool i i didn't know there was
some integration i'm definitely going to
look into that um a question i have for
you first of all this is amazing work
i'm really impressed it's blowing my
mind um
i have played with some of that idea of
object constancy before using d3 and i
see that you're using canvas and web
assembly so
i have is
how do you support or do you support
other layers that people typically put
on top of visualizations like for
example tooltips or
chart annotations
tooltips and sorry what was the other
one
annotations
annotations
yes tooltips we already have annotations
we are working on it uh i i'm pretty
sure if i'll show you the examples uh
you you will see uh which are the ones
that work really well and which are the
ones that we that still need a little
bit of work as as so just to make it
clear we're an early stage startup
uh it's like the three founders working
full-time right now uh we are actually
raising uh another round to to
grow the team bigger and to make our our
tools uh work even better uh but yeah
thanks uh and and i can see now the chat
uh i really
thank you very much for for this uh the
positive uh feedback already and um okay
and and yeah anybody uh with another
question at this point
okay
so
let me quickly
jump back to my browser then the basic
logic of wizu how it works is we have
one
animate method that you
call over and over again
and
and and define charts uh within the
animate method so configure them and
visual will do the rest
easy as it sounds obviously there are
some limitations but that's the basic
logic uh the the animate method has two
parameters uh one that sets the chart
and the second optional one that
determines how easy should animate to
that state actually we're working uh so
we are very keen on making the animation
part uh work out of box for for each and
every case but uh you can you can tweak
you can you can play with it if if you
want to change it in any way and the
first parameter has three properties uh
you have the chance to add the data
in the ipad visa so in the jupyter
version you can add you have to add the
data at once so in the first animate
meth call so when you first call the
animate method uh you have the
configuration part and then you have the
styling of the charts and that's that
um
so just uh to get to a specific example
uh here's a jupiter notebook i hacked a
little bit the css so that the uh output
of the cells appear on the right side
but it's it's a simple uh it's it's just
a jupiter notebook um you
and and uh yeah you you have to you can
use pip to install ipavisu but
uh thanks to the work of one of our
guests uh in the meetup tonight uh
shigreto uh we are we all it's also
available in conda forge and you can
just you know install it
with pip
obviously it's going to tell us that
that it's already installed but
let's wait until the
the cell runs
maybe with the screen sharing part we we
are going to so like while sharing my
screen and running the notebook at the
same time we can have some uh hiccups
with the animation but but
it should be fine so at first we just
import pandas and and read the csv file
and add it to the data frame because
ipad visa works obviously with pandas
as that's the most common way
people are working with data
within within notebooks uh it should be
already there let me just really quickly
see what's going on there so this is
some made up sales data from a company
that has four regions four different
products has some sales data and has
some revenue data and that that's the
the whole data frame is about
and so we we first set the chart
we tell uh how
wide and what the height should be we
add the data to the chart that we uh
previously uh add so like determined
here so that it has the data frame and
then we start with uh with configuring
the chart uh here it's like
what uh what what do we see here so i
mean let me just really quickly run the
chart we see the sales data of shoes
from the data frame the reason for that
is because we filtered the products to
only include the shoes that's uh we
added the data filter you can do that uh
with with the data frame that you added
to ipivizu and then we configured it in
a way that the region is on the x-axis
so north south east and west
the sales so the number of cells is on
the y-axis and also the product will be
there uh but we only see one product at
this time
we add to the label that so the the
markers have the number of the
number of items sold it's the same as
the height of the bars
and we already added the product to the
color but again it has only one color at
this point and we add the title of the
chart and we ran it and that's it
and in the second
cell or in the in the next cell all i do
is i call the animate method once again
as you can see and i just change the
filter uh to include handbags as well
and i change the title accordingly and
if i run it the visual will the ipivi
will just animate between the states and
show the handbags as well this is how
the legend and all the coloring and the
product on the y-axis make sense
in the
next cell all i do is
change the filter again to not include
accessories so we are going to add
gloves this way and as the fourth
like
step i'm going to add accessories as
well it's easy as that uh now the next
step will be a little tricky uh all i do
is change the the number of sold items
to revenue
uh and the which obviously will change
uh the ratio between uh the uh
the the ite uh the the products uh
because uh you know they they their
price is different so uh the number of
uh the the the revenue generated by them
has to be different and as you can see
the dollar signs are written on it and
and you could see how they changed but
still it's a linear thing so uh
you you saw the animation only once but
that's like you know as a start and then
as last but not least uh what i want to
do is to uh
to
aggregate
the revenue generated by the different
products i have to call the animate
method twice i can do just that within a
cell and we are going to just rearrange
the chart to show
uh the amount generated uh by the
different uh the sales of the different
products
what are the so i mean as you can see it
works nicely it do animate uh but there
are a couple of issues uh first there is
a generic logic here so uh i'm pretty
sure that it wasn't absolutely clear
that with these parameters what the
chart will look like we learned that
with with other charting tools that data
scientists are using um
you have let's say chart presets so you
pick the chart type first you say i'm
going to build a bar chart i'm going to
build a scatter plot and then it has
some parameters to fill in and you know
what you're going to end up with that
was one of the most important feedbacks
that we got and also the the the way
that it can only be used one
directionally so that i don't know if i
if i ran uh
this uh cell again uh we will end up
with a different view it's not just like
going back to the previous version uh
because now we have the revenue and the
uh on both axis and and and it's a total
different type of chart here uh so
that's the other issue that we we had to
uh deal with
and uh because of that uh so to tackle
the first issue we introduced presets uh
also the same time as with with the
presentational use case so if you go to
our site you can go to just ipivisio.com
and then go to the examples
you can see 40 plus different
chart types that you could use um like
for example with the scatter plot if you
click on the the thumbnail you can see
the code for all of these charts and and
this is the the
important part so you you add the
scatter so that it's going to be a
scatter plot uh you you add what value
you want to put on the x and the y axis
you tell uh what the it should be
divided by so
scattered by if if you say and and you
can add a title it's it's easier uh to
comprehend that's that's what we figured
also with the
let's say with the stream graph uh you
add that you want to build a stream and
then you add like what's on the x what's
on the y-axis and what is it stacked by
so what are the different layers or
colored uh over there
uh so this is uh this was an important
step forward and and i'm going to show
you another example where these are
already used
we read a different csv file
that has
data about the the the revenue that
different music formats uh generated
over the year in the us so like how much
revenue uh
the music companies generated from dvds
tapes and things like that and
it's already like we
at this point you can see that
we have some limitations in data
management right now so for example
you have to
tell
that you have to manually set that the
year is a string
otherwise visual will
identify it as a number and try to add
it up and things like that which is not
something you would want to do obviously
but we don't handle temporal data at the
moment just categorical and numerical
values
and also
you you we i also added some uh items
with with xero
because
in order to avoid issues with with
ordering uh
it's best if you
you know add data like this
even the empty fields uh it's a little
you know i know it's it's a hassle but
and we're working on uh helping you to
avoid it but
yeah as i said we're at an early stage
right now and as you can see we set the
data type night now
so year became an object
okay so um here i'm going to use the
style i i set it up uh
here separately from the charts
just to
keep the the code for the animate
methods uh
easier simpler and as you can see it has
a hierarchical structure what i set here
is
i i changed the default value for the x
axis label font size and i add a little
angle so i i'm going to turn the uh
label on the x-axis and i i added a my
own color palette that that it's like
just adding a list of colors there with
hexa codes and also uh two bits for the
for the transparency so um yeah and
let's not forget running that or
otherwise we're going to see the default
style values so
here at first i'm going to just
create the chart revenue by music format
from 1973 to 2020 as you can see we can
see the uh
so it's a stream graph
but at first i set it with the with the
old logic it has like six lines of code
and it's not necessarily
straightforward that if you switch the
geometry to area and you align things
along the center that's going to be a
stream graph but if i use the config
stream uh
way then it's just like four
lines of code and it actually results in
the same chart but we think that it's
more more like easier to understand uh
for for uh for everyone and there's
another issue with this chart which is
there are too many years and the labels
are written on top so this is just an
example of an event that i add which
will
just remove all the the year labels
where where where uh where the value is
not divisible by five
so i i ran the
uh
um uh the event and and as you can see
already in the chart only the the years
uh so every fifth year remained there
so a couple of things you can do with
ipy visual independently from the
presets is like uh switz just split i
mean switch on this align stretch
command which will show you the share of
instead of the values
which is i think really nice you can
switch back to the center alignment to
get back to the stream graph you can
split the components just like with the
trump uh example the trump tweet example
to see the trends side by side again
with a single line of comment uh you can
filter
as you saw uh in the previous example
just by adding uh
so like referring to the um the
different elements that are there and
now we zoomed in on streaming and vinyl
again no explanation required for the
audience it's just so obvious what's
going on here and
you can
and and now i'm just going to switch the
filter off and
and and also the splitting of the
components this is the part that my wife
like to call uh the elephants kissing uh
so that's what happens and and you can
see the full chart once again
and uh just as a last step i'm going to
uh turn this into a line chart and show
the components again like sort of next
to each other to see the trends and how
uh one got in front of the other in
terms of revenue over the tank over the
time so this is how we can animate from
a stream draft to a line chart and again
you can see that with the use of presets
i can just use config line and it's a
lot shorter and more straightforward
that i want the year on the x-axis
revenue on the y-axis divided by the
format so again
running this cell will just result in
the same chart as the one before so this
is how we tackle the uh the the uh
generic logic and and the lack of
presets and now they are available you
can find uh examples of all of the
presets that we have
and uh lastly we
also released the a new extension it has
a separate github repository it's called
ipad visual story
as you can see it
i mean
it also uses
pandas and everything but it introduces
two important changes we have now uh
slides and steps
uh step is basically a chart
uh
just like so like one time of calling
the animate methods uh from the previous
version and slide is is uh
a certain point in the story a certain
chart if you will
where you want to stop uh a slide can
consist of like more steps that's
basically it it has a hierarchical
structure and the way it works it's now
we have one
big cell around 200 lines of code
we i again separated the style setting
from all the other part uh we we make a
story here
and we we add the data right away and
the style there we set the size of it
and then we started in the slides and as
you can see we had first a slide and
then a step inside it we filter the data
just like we did before
we configure it
to have something on the y-axis
something on the x-axis and the color as
you saw before add the title at the
geometry you can also use the presets
here it's just it's an earlier example
where i didn't use the presets but you
can you can also use them here and and
here in the step you basically just
configure
an ipad visual chart and then you add it
to the story this slide
then in the next slide
it's basically similar to what we saw
before you set the split to true
and and change the title accordingly and
then you add it to the story as well now
you can also have
slides with multiple steps inside as i
said so first we now have a step where
we switch off the the splitting and we
switch off the filtering of the data in
the next step
but this is to add a new category while
keeping the context and then we add this
slide containing two steps into the uh
story and and and so on so it's
basically just adding steps in size and
so on and at the end of the day uh the
only additional thing you do is to add
story play we also added this event
where we filtered the the years and here
you have a presentation
so it's not only just a chart you can
toggle it to make it full screen
we have the tooltip here that i
mentioned before so if you hover over
the chart you can see
the data that is represented there you
can also add the other type of
information to that data point that's
not visible on the chart and you have
these buttons in in underneath the chart
with which you can move between the
slides uh this is where we splitted the
view this is where we switched the
splitting and added another element this
is basically how much the u.s federal
government spent on r d basically and
and
and this huge purple part is is defense
and uh you can move back and forth you
can do that either with the buttons that
i'm clicking on now or or you can do
that
with the with with the arrow buttons or
with page up page down
you can also use a clicker if you will
you can switch to the person that you
just like before or you can make a
complex transition like zooming in on
the first and the last data point and
then
grouping
the stacked elements and rearranging
them to see how these components changed
from the beginning of the period to the
very end
um
so uh that's
our our newest addition uh and uh we
hope that it so it obviously tackles the
the one directional use challenge and
you can also
with just this simple command the export
to html export the whole thing to html
uh which will be something like this
um yeah it's like
one of my browser extensions made it put
it to sleep it's basically the content
of the chart you can send it uh it
contains the data it contains the
configuration it contains everything uh
within one div so you can also
put it on your website or or do whatever
you please with it
i actually hacked it a little bit the
original one and changed the height of
the chart but apart from that it's it's
actually the same
content that we saw uh in the previous
tab uh within the jupiter notebook
if you want to
i mean
learn more about what we do uh you can
go to ipyvision.com and we will so you
will have
we we have a step-by-step tutorial we
have examples and and you can also go to
the repository as i said uh we it's
available on pipey and and conda uh we
and and it also works within jupiter
google collab databricks kaggle and deep
node notebooks actually the presentation
part is not doesn't work perfectly right
now in data breaks we're addressing that
issue but for example here's the same
stuff uh within uh within a deep note
notebook
it basically works the same as in in a
vanilla jupiter notebook um
this is uh one of the tutorials like the
the list of the tutorial uh um
chapters that we have uh we we really
tried to make it very uh straightforward
but just i had a call with our one of
our early users later earlier today and
he pointed out some things that are
missing so obviously there's always room
for improvement and
like
as you can see
um
you know what is like for example the
chart layout itself is also animated so
you can change the color and call the
animate method and see how it changes
what you're looking at so there's just
plenty of ways you can play with the
charts that you can build with visual to
to come uh to the to the version that
you really like and you would bring to i
don't know a board meeting or any type
of presentation that you're looking for
um
yeah we have the two repositories uh
the ipyvisu or just look for visiohq and
you will find ipivizu an ipad visual
story there if you think it's
interesting what we do i would
definitely appreciate a star but i'm
more even more interested in uh getting
people to use
our tools uh so if if you do that
we have a slack channel we i'm i'm very
approachable uh on
on via email or on twitter or anywhere
else uh please just you know reach out
to me if you
uh if you have any kind of
challenges and and i'd be very happy to
help so i think uh ipadvisor.com might
be the easiest to start with
so
that would be it that was that was what
i wanted to share with before turning to
the questions i have a small favor that
i would like to ask you if you could
type in
type this url in into your browser or in
your phone you will find a short and
sweet survey about
what you think about ibivisu and also
about your experience
presenting uh
data stories to business users yeah i
i i tell i mean i promise you it won't
take more than two minutes for most of
you even less
it is really valuable for us to
understand uh the type of problems that
you are tackling and and whether or not
uh vizu can be
something that or ipa visual that that
can help you with this so
oh yeah thanks dad for for coffee and
peace for for putting it in the chat i
really appreciate that
so i'm just going to stand here for a
minute and then we can
get into the questions if that's okay
for you
thank you so much
peter this is awesome
thanks thanks
i really appreciate it like one of the
uh
audience here uh eye candy
saying
eye candy i like that
um
all right so questions and uh feedbacks
anyone
peter um
how many languages uh have you tested
within the jupiter notebook
i saw pi you were demonstrating with
python but i was wondering if if you had
tested with r or uh julia
uh we haven't tested it yet uh i would
be surprised if uh it would work without
any
uh previous work from our side
but basically we use the same technology
that's that as plotly so it's actually
uh
the the javascript library is being
called uh
with the python code that you write in
jupiter it's getting translated into
javascript and then we just show the
canvas and and and and draw the chart
over there
uh
i i'm i'm pretty sure
it's doable but uh so far uh we were
focusing on python as the most popular
language
uh among data scientists
i can't blame you there
low hey low hanging fruit
okay
yeah i was wondering the same thing um
i'm an r person then
more more like our person that's that's
what i was uh uh wondering too uh
you know if you you know have have it
tested you know art i'll be you know
even more awesome
take your time
thanks for the feedback actually this is
an open source project both parts so if
you feel like this would need an r
interface uh we'd be more than happy to
support you along the way if you decide
to to build it
i'm not sure we have the means to focus
on that right now but
i definitely appreciate the feedback
i have a quick question peter if you
don't mind um
not at all
please thanks
uh will you configure
all those items um
do you have a library where what kind of
uh
item we need to configure beforehand
um you know it's like a
um our library right whenever you search
for a function
you
read the library in you know how many
arguments you know in the um in a
function
so that we can you know type
code that in right so do you have such a
library
uh so i guess what you mean is some sort
of uh tab suggestion
that would show you the different
available parameters
uh yeah we we have those we we have
typescript enabled and
we have uh also within jupiter
it should be available i haven't tested
it myself so that's why i'm i only say
it should be available but i'm pretty
sure it is
this sort of tab uh assistance that you
get the list of parameters that you need
to fill in
in our case there's a lot of yeah code
completion thank you
yeah in in
in our case uh uh there are a lot of
parameters that are optional uh that
would change how i mean for example the
splitting uh of or the alignment that
you that i showed you uh these are all
you could use it in any charts uh or or
or the filter you might want to filter
the data or not but the basic structure
is there and also the optional
parameters are listed uh
for that so if you use it within an ide
uh you would definitely get all the
suggestions and and and this completion
uh
features that that
thank you
anyone else have any questions for peter
uh i have two i don't want to monopolize
or anything uh one is more technical um
i remember when i was looking into
object constancy and some of the papers
that the guy from d3 postdoc wrote about
it
he was saying in some cases animation
adds value because you showed like when
when you're changing the filter you're
showing the values are growing or
reducing but in some cases the animation
can be misleading say you change a trick
from you know sales to another like
population that have nothing to do with
each other in that case you really
shouldn't be doing animation because you
kind of like you're saying the value is
growing from sales to population and
that doesn't make sense
do you take some of how how do you do uh
with that do you take that into account
and you try to to communicate that by
you know
animating zero and then back to a value
or i don't know i'm just wondering
[Music]
um
not not at this point i mean i i
understand i agree that that object
constants so yes
that that's one of uh the
[Music]
um
so what you mentioned uh from the
creators of these three it's it's an
object consistency is is an important
starting point for us uh so i can relate
to that with with the uh what you we
should make available for people or not
uh we we don't take a strong standpoint
at this point we this this whole thing
is for experts now uh data scientists
and developers we we plan to build this
into
uh
a tool for end users
uh later on so to actually build the
graphical user interface that andrew was
originally set out to build and there uh
such things uh are crucially important
uh to take into account to to help
people not to tell fake stories of data
but you can only go to a certain point
with that you you cannot stop people lie
with charts and things like that
or make wrong decisions
you you have to
have some kind of analytical
understanding uh in order not to to mess
it up
gotcha
my second question it's not related to
the technology but i'm very curious
about the business model and how you see
the company growing um like i love that
you guys are going the open source route
as a data data analyst data scientist
and i'm looking forward to play with the
tool
um but i'm very curious as a company on
the data visualization space since
you're making this available to open
source how we find the company and have
a revenue stream right thanks i really
appreciate the question uh and i have
actually a backup slide for that
so uh we we don't want to monetize the
data scientist uh use case we we are
happy that uh people seem to be just
like yourself interested in it and want
to play with it and want to
uh start building with it and we already
have some nice example of that and we
know that
so we we want to enable uh the use of
these stories that the data scientists
build within bi tools uh and
do using extensions that are available
in in all the big bi vendors uh
products such as tableau power bi and
all the others
so we want to
help
the the the reusing and the the the the
regular use of the the content and the
stories and the insights that were uh
created by the data scientists
by the business stakeholders and and
those would be paid services so that's
what this is the uh the way we we see uh
moving forward and actually building a
business around it uh we we're already
in touch for example with the
dutch company called infotopics is the
global market leader in building tableau
extensions and they already
made just sort of like a proof of
concept thing where uh
visu runs within tableau and and that's
so as one of our uh
advisors said
um
nobody has a notebook budget and
everybody has a bi budget so
we're looking for
we're trying to focus on the bi budget
obviously
cool
peter i had a couple quick questions as
well
um so i think from the data science
standpoint you're focusing on being able
to present results which is uh is really
cool there's another big area that we
hit which is kind of the
eda
exploring data and analyzing it
do you
have
yeah i think some of this does directly
apply there but i guess my question
would be have you thought about applying
it in that space and
how might the product change to be a
kind of data exploration tool
yes absolutely actually the the original
vision uh behind vizu is to
uh
inter so intertwine exploration
storytelling and regular use it's it's
we we think that it's it's quite
unnatural that these are so split up
these phases when and uh
due to this uh the flexibility of our
technology this is absolutely possible
we just as an early stage startup have
to take one step at a time but for
example what what we're working right on
right now is uh to enable
uh some sort of next steps uh for data
scientists again so to
make it like okay i have a chart here i
want to see the distribution of the
elements or i want to aggregate it or i
want to rearrange it or i want to zoom
in so to to focus on the actions that
are in many cases are actually
exploratory and not about uh just you
know okay i have all the results let's
put it together into a story so we are
already trying to focus on that and
coming up with some new features that
would enable you to do that
thanks for the question
for that
um the other question maybe a little
more technical um
i think to have a tool that's powerful
you know you make a lot of decisions for
us
i'm wondering
if there's kind of access to a lower
layer to
tweak some of those things so for
example where you put your labels right
you show us you can rotate some of them
if i want to move labels to the top of a
bar instead of the middle or even
outside of it or put a background color
on it or something like that do we have
like that kind of station power or do
you kind of make those decisions for us
uh you you have those options actually
all of those that you just mentioned
uh and we are happy to add uh any
similar features that that are requested
we we
we are very focused on on
um enabling uh or like or enable you to
build nice and clean and good looking
charts by default
but uh we are very we are absolutely
happy if you tweak them and and you know
turn it to to your own uh as i said with
all the animations uh you can even tweak
those and if you remember the part where
we switched the orientation and and and
so the total number of uh values
or the total number of of the revenue
per product the label moved to the right
side of the bars and that's something we
do automatically because that's how it
looks we think the nicest but you can
override this setting uh with one line
of code uh if if that's not something
you would want
that's awesome
thank you
peter uh peter i do have one i have one
question for you um
this goes this kind of dovetails on
ted's uh eda question
there's a
company that's
part of although kind of a spin-off of
sas
called jump jmp and
and they um
their
mission or goal is to
make the make the data
visible
to you know to the statistician to the
to to whatever that where do we
understand data visually
much much more accurately than we do
uh through just a number numbers on
numbers on a page for instance um
and i was wondering if there had been
any thought
amongst the leaders of uh the visu team
of uh
of looking at potentially
down the road doing something
um
like jump
[Music]
i i'm not sure i completely understand
how this thing works it sounds like
something we we would want to do but uh
well they they they put their they put
you know statistic statistics
on you know they they basically oh this
is the data let me let me tell you the
statistics but they show you the
statistics
graphically
yeah absolutely yes yes uh this is
something that so this is uh
absolutely uh something that uh we would
want to visual to be used for we
i mean obviously we are totally biased
here but
we think that uh
this technology would enable everyone to
have just a better uh
more intimate relationship with data to
have a discussion or a dialogue with
data if you will
we we don't want you to fiddle with
spreadsheets and and coding or you i
mean it's a different matter but but
average business users definitely
and uh and yeah just looking at things
and and then tweaking the chart itself
uh with with the use of buttons instead
of the the codes that is available now
is is something that would actually
i think empower a lot of people uh to to
just make better sense of what's going
on
there are some
like information about how this whole
self-service bi thing is is catching on
and and even gartner says that
you cannot go over 30 percent of
employees in in big corporations who
could actually make data-driven
decisions and use analytics for their uh
for for doing so uh because they just
don't have the the ability to to
uh like
manipulate data visualize data and
understand what's going on there and and
we feel or we we hope that that our
super visual approach and the fact that
you're playing with the visuals can
change all this at least that's what
we're working on
uh nasi if i see you uh share the gemini
uh
research paper
thanks a lot for that
okay yeah it does i remember that i have
seen something like that
automatic transition generated on the
vegas space and that was the genuine
product you're probably familiar with
that but i just yes yes i i saw the uh
saw them actually the it's it's the same
guy behind the like that you mentioned
and it's a shame that it doesn't come to
mind who also did the data wranglers uh
stuff
um
yeah so
uh is that the same guy between these
three um
uh
yeah the the the the idl
jeff here yeah jeffrey here yes jeff
yeah that's the guy and it's and gemini
is actually done by one of his students
at the university of washington yeah
it's it's it's uh it's something uh that
that closely is closely related to what
we do uh but still a different approach
and uh
yeah
but
i would love to have a conversation with
jeffrey here about uh all things visual
i i mean uh the the guy is is brilliant
and and all the work that he's done and
and everything is it's like
top top of you know there is a new there
is a this conference coming up soon
probably too too late for the next one
but that big ieee visualization uh
conference
his team is of those papers that come
out of the washington lab all they're
always presenting on that one i would
strongly suggest that you at some point
look into presenting there too
great thanks for the suggestion uh can
you maybe type in the name of the
conference because i'm not sure i could
catch
thanks i'd really appreciate it and
and
am i you were the one because i'm sorry
there are no faces here so it's it's not
always easy to identify who's talking
but you you're the one who works at mode
right
that's correct yeah okay and by
coincidence i work that jump too so i
saw two of my companies
talking about today that was fine well
you know it's just like i i really would
want to connect uh with you after the
meet up and you know
i would i would love to have you
understand what you saw and and yeah
let's let's continue this discussion
thank you very oh yeah the ievs yeah i
know i i attended it uh
like uh remotely last year it and and
that's where where actually the gemini
thing was i i saw the presentation there
thanks
i think david uh have a question for you
peter um do you have any built-in tools
for clustering or dimensional
dimensionality reduction
dimension reduction yes
not right now
um
we understand that it's a challenge and
yeah actually every
chart has a lot of
limitations in terms of how many
dimensions it can
show
[Music]
but
we we are we and we will tackle it when
we get there
actually uh there are a couple of
approaches we can take
but uh i think most of the cases when
somebody's dealing with data
it's it's not the
high dimensional type
but that's absolutely spot on
again thank you
yeah right now
yeah for right now um most of the uh
high dimensional uh data uh if we really
want to cluster it and uh virtualize it
in a two-dimensional graph
um
t s and e is the most common method
we're using the t distributed i think
everybody t distributed
um stochastic
neighborhood
embedding right so
yeah
all right so um i think we're
running out of time already
out of time
um
i'm not quite sure if we have anyone uh
who would like to present the lightning
talk today
um
thank you very much for having me just
to close off my session thanks again for
all the questions those were brilliant
and thank you very much for appreciating
what we do
yep yeah you're welcome